[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faisons un test fermé les yeux voilà et
imaginez vous dans votre paradis le
vôtre celui que vous imaginez pour vous
même qu'est ce que vous voyez
qu'est ce que vous entendez qu'est ce
que vous sentez à présent ouvrir les
yeux est ce moi vous poser une question
combien d'entre vous dans 7 salles
peuvent dire qu'ils ont vu de la beauté
dans leurs pas radiés combien d'entre
vous peuvent dire que c'était beau
évidemment à présent une autre question
combien d'entre vous peuvent dire qu'ils
ont vu entendu senti ou même ressentiez
un ou plusieurs éléments de la nature
ça peut être n'importe quoi une cascade
une brise sur la peau un grand arbre ok
garder ça en tête on va y revenir plus
tard en polynésie contrairement à
d'autres endroits du monde un peu plus
urbanisées on a tous une histoire plus
ou moins intimes avec la nature vous
avez certainement la brousse aujourd'hui
je vous propose de vous présenter la
mienne j'ai grandi sur l'île de moorea
une île qui encore aujourd'hui reste
très sauvage
à l'époque ma mère me racontait que les
routes n'étaient même pas encore
goudronnée c'était de la soude de corail
on me demande souvent de quoi était fait
mes jeunes années d'enfance
ces images à vous donner une petite idée
barboter ou nager dans le lagon pendant
des heures ramasser des coquillages sur
la plage cueillir des fleurs danser je
ne sais pas si c'est comment à tous les
enfants de polynésie mais en tout cas
mon enfance c'était ça cette image c'est
un bon résumé de ce que j'avais autour
de moi au quotidien des grandes vallées
des grandes montagnes des bd lagon des
couches et d'élever seul est à couper le
souffle
vraiment j'ai été gâté pendant très
longtemps jusqu'à très tard on n'avait
pas télévision chez moi et ça je peux
dire que ça fait une chose sur moi ça
m'a permis de ne pas être influencé par
la conception de la beauté imposée par
la société de consommation
si vous connaissez un peu mort et à vous
serez également que là bas c'est encore
très rare aujourd'hui de voir au bord de
la route des panneaux publicitaires nous
vraiment je peux dire qu'en grandissant
là bas je me suis créé une conception de
la beauté
vraiment personnel est en vérité à 100%
inspirées de la nature
ça va vous expliquer là vous allez
sûrement pensé à ça ok voter on pense à
ces grandes femme élancée sur les
podiums en lingerie vous pouvez oublier
tout de suite parce que c'est pas du
tout à ça que je fais référence
aujourd'hui pour moi la beauté c'est
deux choses
harmonie et équilibre est en fait centre
surprise on se rend compte que harmonie
et équilibre
c'est aussi deux caractéristique
primordiale des écosystèmes de la nature
dans une forêt par exemple vous allez
avoir le petit oiseau qui va avoir
besoin de faire son nid et pour faire
son nid
là on va être là et va lui donner un
habitat mais là on va aussi avoir besoin
qu on disperse et graines dans la forêt
n'est ce pas donc loiseau va prendre ce
rôle il va manger des graines il valait
dispersés ensuite dans la forêt mais ces
petites graines elles ont besoin de
pousser
elles ont toutes un sol fertile et pour
ce faire toutes les plantes de la nature
vont perdre leurs feuilles qui petit à
petit vent s'est décomposé et vont venir
nourrir le sol
la rivière va apporter un micro climat
frais et agréable pour que toutes ces
plantes ou ces plantes puissent pousser
et que tous ces oiseaux et ces animaux
puissent survivre tout simplement vous
voyez tout est parfaitement orchestré
n'est ce pas tout est équilibré tout est
harmonieux et ce qui est magnifique dans
ces conditions là c'est que la vie s'en
suit alors si cette définition de la
beauté à l'échelle un petit peu macro
vous paraît encore un peu flou je vous
propose de regarder cette sélection
d'image qui sont toutes les images de
choses de la nature vous allez pouvoir
reconnaître peut-être des feuilles des
fleurs des écorces l'oeil d'un reptile
les tentacules d'un pool par exemple et
là vous voyez des textures des couleurs
des formes et peut-être même des odeurs
qui sont toutes parfaitement équilibrée
et harmonieuse harmonie j'ai pas choisi
ce thème pour rien harmonie c'est un
terme qu'on utilise très souvent quand
on décrit la musique un son une voix est
en fait tout ça en termes scientifiques
c'est quoi c'est tout simplement des
ondes des vibrations
n'est ce pas pour moi la beauté le vrai
beau c'est quelque chose qui émane il
émane quelque chose de tellement fort et
ça nous donne envie sont inspirés et 50
et de 100 ans entourée
ma passion en grandissant à moorea et
aussi avec les expériences que j'ai eu
dans ma jeune vie
c'est devenu la poursuite de la beauté
m'entourer du beau tout le temps le plus
possible et en fait par conséquent c'est
un peu devenu la passion de la nature
alors plus que le mot passion c'est le
terme blesse que j'aimerais introduire
pour vous aujourd'hui blesse c'est un
mot anglais qui en france est le plus ou
moins dire béatitude
mais je trouvais que le mot glisse phone
est tellement bien qu'on va le garder
ainsi hockey béatitude c'est l'état de
bonheur suprême et c'est une définition
presque spirituelle en fait parce que
c'est de ce terme qu'on fait référence
lorsqu'on fait référence au bonheur
qu'on ressent au paradis ça vous dit
quelque chose
donc mon blé sur moi comme je vous le
disais c'est devenu petit à petit la
poursuite la quête de cette beauté
à 16 ans j'ai la chance de voyager en
équateur pendant une journée nous avons
pu nous nous comment dire visité la
forêt amazonienne nous sommes allés
vraiment à la frontière de la forêt
amazonienne un peu mythique 1
c'était tellement beau j'étais comblée
j'étais sous le charme et pourtant il y
avait quelque chose qui faisait mouche
le guide touristique nous a dit non loin
de là à quelques kilomètres seulement
il ya des experts et des hectares de
forêt vierge ils sont en train d'être
massacrés ils sont en train d'être coupé
tout ça pourquoi pour des raisons
économiques ou des raisons industrielles
là ça a été mon déclic personnel
c'est vraiment là où je me suis dit que
cette beauté de la nature que je prenais
pour acquise dans ma petite bulle à
montréal avec tous ces beaux couchers de
soleil et ses beaux lagons et ses belles
montagnes mais en fait c'était bien plus
fragile que ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
j'ai commencé des études dans
développement durable dans l'écologie
non pas juste pour une raison utile qui
étaient de protéger la nature et parce
que je voulais protéger et promouvoir ce
qu'on a de plus magnifique sur cette
terre est aussi je dois avouer un petit
peu parce que j'ai une obsession pour
les jardins une obsession et je voudrais
créer dans ma vie ce que j'appelle des
jardins magiques c'est des endroits qui
sont tellement beau et écologiques
qu'ils inspirent l'homme à poursuivre
son propre blé et à changer pour le
meilleur
cette quête un peu insensé du bo elle
m'a emmené assez loin
professionnellement du moins pour mon
jeune âge je trouve que j'ai quand même
réussi à apporter un petit quelque chose
mais là on m'a vraiment en est loin
si géographiquement parlant au maroc
j'ai campé en plein milieu des dunes de
sable pourquoi parce que je rêvais de
voir un lever de soleil dans le désert
du sahara
quand je vivais au brésil ça m'arrivait
parfois de me lever en plein milieu de
la nuit qu'elle avait beaucoup des
toiles pour aller me baigner dans ce
black complètement gelé pourquoi parce
qu'on pouvait voir la réflexion des
étoiles dans le lac noir et j'avais
l'impression de me baigner dans le ciel
étoilé
une histoire un peu plus drôle cette
fois à zion aux états unis où j'ai forcé
ma pauvre soeur qui dans la salle
aujourd'hui à faire une aventure de
camping sauvage avec la pluie le vent
des voisins de camping assez douteux et
tout ça pour quoi
parce que je voulais monter sur cette
montagne pour célébrer mon 21e
anniversaire
et ça c'est la tête de ma soeur au
réveil dans la vie de tous les jours le
blesse pour moi c'est par exemple design
et mon petit jardin mon petit jardin
magique avec mes petits fruits mais
aussi légumes ça c'est mon blesse m'ont
blessé aussi alarmes à répétition danse
tahitienne tous les soirs et voir mes
amis et rire et danser et chanter
ensemble en harmonie faire des costumes
traditionnels avec des feuilles des
fleurs des écorces qui viennent de la
nature il ferait bien de vous raconter
aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire de mon
blesse et en fait si je me fie au nombre
de mains qui se sont levés dans la salle
tout à l'heure quand je vous demandais
combien de personnes ont vu de la beauté
ou de la nature dans leur paradis
il ya des chances que votre blé soit au
moins un petit peu en lien avec ça
pensez-y
mais au lieu de vous convaincre que la
nature ou la beauté vous feront le plus
grand bien dans votre vie même si j'en
suis persuadé ce que je voudrais vous
dire c'est poursuivez votre propre
glisse tout simplement à tout prix à ce
qui vous emmènera très très loin je fais
partie de ces personnes qui sont
persuadés qu' on a tous dans notre vie
une mission à accomplir on a un rôle à
jouer dans ce grand écosystème et ça à
vrai dire je n'invente pas vraiment vous
souvenez l'exemple de la forêt et
graines l'oiseau l'arbre le sol les
racines la rivière
ils ont tous un rôle à jouer et non
enlever un seul de ces éléments et votre
écosystème s'effondre littéralement
alors pourquoi ce que nous êtres humains
on croirait être si différente ça au
final on est les animaux dans un grand
écosystème non on a tous une nature est
humble et ce différend moi par exemple
je vais aimer l'agriculture et quelqu'un
va peut être aimé la pêche
je vais aimer travailler en extérieur et
quelqu'un va peut-être préféré
travailler devant 1 devant un ordinateur
chez soi je préfère les climats chauds
et quelqu'un va préférer les climats
froids c'est normal la nature est faite
comme ça est extrêmement diverse et le
contraire mais ce serait vraiment
ennuyant on est donc tous partie
prenante dans ce gros écosystèmes et si
en fait notre responsabilité de suivre
son propre blaise parce que c'est celui
là qui va nous emmener sur le bon chemin
alors je sais la question que vous allez
me poser maintenant est comment est ce
qu'on sait c'est quoi mon blesse comment
est ce que je sais c'est quoi ma mission
la réponse la plus simple c'est on le
sait pas on le sent mais ça c'est une
théorie abstraite et je préfère pas nous
embrouiller avec ça plus tôt je préfère
vous partager - de mon expérience
personnelle comment est ce que moi je
ressens mon propre blesse tout
simplement j'ai l'impression d'avoir des
palpitations ici au niveau de la
poitrine
un peu comme en ce moment j'ai des
palpitations mais c'est un peu comme de
l'adrénaline un peu comme de
l'excitation et c'est quand je ressens
ça j'ai une idée et je ressens ça et je
sais que c'est exactement dans cette
voie que je vais aller peu importe ce
qu'elle va m'emmener
je sais que c'est la bonne voie je vois
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui qui sont
assez désoeuvrés son few de la vie qu'on
leur propose même temps comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait leur en vouloir
moi par exemple quand j'ai eu mon bac
m'a donné deux options sciences po ou
une haute école de commerce et moi ce à
quoi je pensais c'était ok et mon jardin
magique alors en fait pire que des
jeunes désoeuvrés c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'adultes que je vois
juste satisfait d'avis qu'ils ont bâti
mais juste un peu ennuyé également ils
ont laissé de côté leur blesse parce que
c'est pas important
ils sont en train de faire face à une
vie d'adulte est-ce pas qu'en fait c'est
ça qu'on transmet aussi à nos élèves à
nos élèves à nos enfants et nos jeunes
c'est l'ennui
non c'est quelque chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que la vie est bien trop
merveilleuse et rempli de choses pour
qu'on ait le temps de s'ennuyer
il faut être curieux et le blesse vous
allez me dire oui mais c'est bien tu va
voyager c'est bien tu as fait si tu as
fait ça
le blessé dans les petites choses de la
vie c'est comme elle sur son canapé un
dimanche soir tout seul et se prendre un
fou rire devant sa vérité sa série télé
c'est comme par exemple danser dans sa
cuisine
on est en train de faire cuire des pâtes
ou c'est quand tu prends une petite
graine la mettre dans le sol et dia bâ
peut-être qu'elle va donner des frayeurs
qu'elle va donner des fleurs un jour
rires pensée lente et passer mon blé
elle est le vôtre
merci
[Applaudissements]